hey welcome to the final part of the
session and it's my pleasure to
introduce stephen brenner from
university of california in berkeley
thank you so it's my pleasure to be able
to tell you about some work that was
done by a really great post doctor in my
roof
this is working you did quite a while
ago and we're still working on getting
out for publication it was um and i'm
really excited to have a chance to share
it with you it's what we call time bombs
in large-scale biological public data
um and i'm trying to motivate what's
happening with these data but what
happened with a
fairly um well-reported case of
something called the golden state killer
this was a
murderer who was active decades ago
um who was involved in many murders and
also many rapes and he had a very
stereotypical way in which he would
carry these out which was particularly
sadistic
and this went on for years terrorizing
um areas in california
and then
you just stopped the guide seemed to
just disappeared
and no one knew what happened
and eventually he was caught
and a few years ago he was
convicted um
and is now in jail
so how's it after decades they were able
to find this guy with him not doing
anything in that intervening time
so the approach um was that they had the
invictus investigation evidence
they had dna from crime scenes from from
the 80s when particularly for all the
rapes occurred there was very extensive
dna material
they knew that also a lot of information
about him which we call
quasi-identifiers that he was male they
knew about how old he was they knew
where he was active so therefore it
would likely where he was living um they
knew he was he was a criminal and had
some data about that that based on the
way he committed his crimes there was a
belief that he was probably military or
associated with police
and that was the first speculation about
him and this type of data that's
normally what detectives use to try to
solve cases
but it wasn't enough that this was not
enough to solve that case alone
but then
several years ago um i guess about five
years ago they decided to take this dna
data they had from the crime scenes
and they uploaded it to a database
called get match
so get match is a database where people
typically look to find their relatives
if they say one they use 23andme and
they want to find relatives who might
have used ancestry they upload to get
match the idea is they can find people
from who basically had their genotyping
done from different databases so people
basically put in these databases their
genotypes and their names and then you
can find who your relatives are so they
took this guy's genotype and they
uploaded there
he had not participated in this and so
his relative so he was not in there but
what they found were some distant
relatives and with those distant
relatives they were able to infer an
ancestor who lived probably on the order
of a hundred years ago
and then working with genealogists this
was not a trivial thing i want to
emphasize it was not a straightforward
thing they then actually reconstructed
the entire pedigree of the descendants
of that ancestor and who were all the
people that were living today
who would be the relatives of that that
were matched um indirectly in this ged
match database
and when they went through all the
people living today that there were only
two of them that were a plausible match
with the quasi-identifiers they had one
of them was most compelling they went to
the guy's house collected a cup that he
had discarded took a dna sample from
that this was a perfect match to the dna
sample they then brought him in and did
a proper forensic test and confirmed
that he was that he was the golden state
killer
so there was all this indirection in
using these public genotype database
matches that allow this to happen now
there's a whole industry literally an
industry around doing this it's
been done in um probably now hundreds of
cases it's actually restricted at a
federal level how can be done it's
states though are often much less
restricted in how they can uh pursue
this
and it's this type of general idea is
the type of idea we're going to use in
trying to think about biological public
data as well
and part reason that this works
is from this work is motivated by this
work by johnny verlick
arguing that something like 60
of all
americans of european descent will be
identifiable by a third degree relative
or closer in these public databases so
now there is a big database that
basically matches people to genomes not
everyone but at least via relatives
and the second thing is realizing that
you actually don't need that many quasi
identifiers to be able to uniquely
identify someone so if this also worked
by anybody like this which i thought he
you know laid out quite nicely that if
you typically know the year of someone's
birth that they monthly burst so
basically their birthday in their zip
code that you almost always will then
have enough information
enough this information to actually
uniquely identify someone within the u.s
population
and so if you have a little bit of data
that you have already easily available
you don't need that much more to get to
unique identification of an individual
so how can personal privacy be wrapped
be breached by a biological data so
first imagine you have a perfect genomic
database the genotypes and has you know
identifiable information alice fatima
and ming and what their genotypes are
you have some genetic study that's been
performed that has gene that has
phenotypes associated with it and this
is also publicly available you have
these genotypes here near the phenotypes
and the phenotypes which emphasize these
do not need to be genetic phenotypes in
fact it's more useful if they are not
genetic phenotypes but things have been
reported as part of as part of the study
so that you know this individual who has
lithogen type had covet had coping 19
this one here had bipolar disorder
you can see that obviously if you had
databases like these it would be trivial
to figure out uh you'll do the matching
and figure out you know who had what
disease it's that alice would be able to
match her genotype one to this genotype
c and determine that alice had bipolar
disorder and so if you made these data
fully public you would very readily
compromise people's privacy
were the case this was public and this
is public
and because of that neither of those are
public any of those really exist in this
form
you can also do indirect matching as
well and so one simple way of indirect
matching you'd imagine instead of having
a genotype instead the database has
reads and you have rna-seq reads and
then from the rna-seq reads you can then
compute an intermediate
of what the genetic variants are from
those reeds and then from that match
those genetic variants then to a
genotype and so in this case you'd be
able to match with bob with this
genotype maps the gene of type variants
which were inferred from rna-seq reads
and then learned that bob has hepatitis
b so you would also not want to
release a data set where you have
data that could readily lead to a
computer intermediate that could be
mapped to a public database
and so we don't do that by and large
that
when we have rna-seq reads that those
are controlled axis so here i'm showing
you the data for example um for tcga and
basically the reads are controlled
access and with the gene read count the
tpms are publicly and unrestrictedly
available
it turns out that is a problem
and it was a problem identified for
quite a long time
because what you can do is from gene
expression levels
infer eqtl
genotypes this is something that markers
in this group identified about a decade
ago
and then this eqtl genotype can be a
computed intermediate that then you can
go ahead and match to the genotypes and
let me show you how this works it's
really quite simple in practice that if
you have
gene expression levels that are known to
be associated with particular genotypes
this is what an eqtl is where the aa is
relatively low expression the gg is
relatively high expression you can
literally just run backwards and say
okay if i see that this is expressed
this gene expressed at quite a high
level then it's very likely that the
allele this position is gg
so the question is how many of these
alleles can you actually compute with
what degree of reliability and how where
are these to the extent that you're able
to actually get enough information from
them to be able to compute these types
sorry go back and compute these types of
links over here
and so they introduced this idea back in
2012 and so decade ago and then updated
in 2016.
but they actually the time said this
wasn't really a big deal
you could just be masked out
the really problematic alleles and and
have them not be part of your data and
then everything would be okay
and that's the part actually which turns
out to have actually been the opposite
of what they anticipated so there's two
reasons why they thought that this was
not really a serious problem the first
reason is they thought you really
wouldn't be able to learn enough about
these eq genotypes and even if you could
then again you could mask out the ones
that are most informative and then
everything would be okay
the second thing is that there was no
large database
of of the genomes
that there is no database even today
that has genotype in the name there is
this
ged match database
um however that that get matched
database you can't it doesn't not
actually a database or you can go into
and simply say here's the genocide but i
want to match it you have to work
through their resources which are
limited in what they can do because
they're intended to be able to find
relative by identity by ascent not to
kind of do this type of matching which
um with the eqtls
but it turns out
that while back when they did their
analysis the power to infer um answers
for relatives from the um
expression levels was relatively limited
that today it's profound
and as our knowledge of eqtl continues
to improve
this will continue to get better and so
his argument at the time was like well
if we really care about we could filter
out these 50 or then maybe these hundred
different most powerful eqtls just not
give the expression levels of those
genes they're associated with those
httls but what that would do is if we
taken those ones so basically have the
effect of taking this curve here
basically bringing it down you know here
to down to zero but you can see that
still this curve which would still give
you enough information today to still
easily reveal who someone is and if we
then you know took out these ones here
based on what we know today that it
would that then you might be able to
make it so it's hard to identify someone
but later on we may learn more eqtls and
then you still over time be able to
re-identify someone
so this idea that the eq tells don't
tell you enough
has proven not to be true over time
um
and it turns out that the other issue of
whether this database exists has also
proven not to be true over time that my
postdoc z chang was able to show that
with a database like get match
you can actually upload a fake profile
and be able to do the matching so we
were very careful with this i should say
we didn't upload any real profiles and
we worked with the database to do this
in a way that was all appropriate and so
there was no real person being matched
here but rather identifying what would
happen but if you actually match a real
gene versus a real genome you get a very
very significant match you match up with
something random you get nothing you can
actually also identify
offsprings and siblings as well
so we are not able to go out to third
degree relatives the way is currently
done with forensic matches we are
currently able to easily go out to
secondary to first-degree relatives and
we probably could go out to
second-degree relatives so it's not yet
you know 60 of the u.s european
population but it's definitely going in
that direction so these two big hurdles
that were thought to be a problem
have now both been overcome
and so from our perspective that
releasing expression level information
is releasing data that has high risk of
being re-identifiable for substantial
fraction individuals either now or in
the near future
so a lot of people say well this is not
really real world risk because who would
do this you'd have to be deliberately
trying to be nefarious to go and do this
and why would anyone do that
well there are thousands of successful
ransomware attacks every single day
there are lots of evil people out there
and they try to do bad things to get
income and so you can imagine they'll be
easy for someone to want to do something
like this and then to do this type of
compute is really no harder than doing a
ransomware type attack and in the same
way that ransomware has been set up as
you know as a service type approach you
can imagine this becoming a service as
well um
so that's one possibility that's the
evil possibility
um people use it for insider trading you
get information about who is sick and
what's going to happen with them you
know if you'd known for example that
steve jobs had pancreatic cancer that
probably that you could have made some
money on the stock market at that time
um
that you could use it for profiling in
various ways but the most interesting
one though i think is public interest
you can actually imagine cases where
someone would do this because they're
trying to think they're trying to do
something good
and the case that came up that actually
led me to realize this was the story of
this individual here my senior jeffrey
burrell
who was the general secretary of the u.s
bishops conference so a very
high-ranking person in the catholic
church
and a
journalist a set of journalists working
for an organization called the pillar
which is sort of a catholic um news
organization
basically identified that he was
involved in sexual misconduct
so how did this happen
these titles from the washington post
laid out very clearly
that basically they were able to like
locate him using grinder data so grinder
sells their location data in an
anonymized quote unquote anonymized form
they're able to locate you know who was
going to the catholic you know place and
then who was going to other places
where they didn't think he should be
and were able to figure out who he was
and figure out and basically he resigned
immediately once these data became
released
and from their perspective the
journalists were trying to identify
someone who was involved in misconduct
under the scope of definitions they had
and you can imagine a journalist could
do the same sort of thing trying to use
the genomic data the same way and to
play this out into one type of scenario
imagine bob
so bob is a pilot and um he has diabetes
so he joins a study that's studying
diabetes and he keeps information
private the researchers try to be very
cautious they only release the tpms
because that's what they're told are
safe they're very do everything
according to the standards bob lear you
know tries to find some relatives he
does 23andme uploads his data into get
match and later on you have um um clark
kent who goes and tries to uh ken clark
to try to figure out um you know who are
the pilots who have diabetes it's
illegal to be a pilot if you have
diabetes
and so
bob has actually been keeping his
diabetes secret so he doesn't want to
lose his job
and so they go and they find basically
look for all people on a product
studying diabetes who are people with
diabetes they infer the genotypes from
the expression levels in that database
as well as having the information that
was put in here about example it's an
individual with male depression and
their year birth year they go and take
this inferior genotype search against
dead match and they find bob and with
this little information they can find
out who bob is precisely and then be
able to out him uh as being someone who
is illegally flying and be able to
basically destroy his career and but
they're doing this nominally in the
public interest and they will do it
because you participate in the study
um and so even from this public interest
standpoint you can imagine you can see
how our research data could do great
harm to the participants who've been
promised privacy in these studies
and it's not just expression data in
fact there are many different types of
data for which we have lots of qtls
they're associated with them and some of
these actually turn out to be even more
powerful
than the expression data that's been
probably studied most broadly
dna's hypersensitive sites in particular
have an enormous amount of power and
probably appear to be more tissue in
specific for these analyses and so may
be more generalizable we've also looked
at splicing splicing is sort of where um
expression was
about five years ago and whether it will
get better or not and remains to be seen
so there are many many types of data
that potentially could cause risks that
we now currently freely and
unrestrictedly share
and so why this is happening
is that because over time we have
more data
we have more types of data more things
that are public
more of the qtl get inferred that comes
from
being able to do better mapping and then
we've improved algorithm for trying to
actually do these computations here
and so over time we're going to get
better and better at having the data
that allows us to re-identify people
from the limited public data that ends
up being released
and so this is a summary of where we
think things are today
um that
things that are green are things that
are safe to share things that are red or
things that today already have a
practical concern um where it could
affect a potentially large population
and then the yellow and orange are sort
of more theoretical concerns today but
could be a concern in the future
and so almost every type of data that's
out there um
in large scale
tens right now seems to be at risk of
having potentially some problem in the
future um this actually was a recently
updated figure because originally we
didn't know how to do anything with high
c
and it turned out that someone might
give a talk and point us to actually no
actually you can do it this way and so
you know there are
all kinds of this it's actually a very
indirect approach you have to use but
it's the one that actually is very
informative um you basically look for
what regions of the high sea data are
missing and that gives you information
about structural variants that are
present that you can then use for
re-identification
and so all kinds of data can potentially
cause these kinds of risks and the main
thing you can see is that the risks grow
over time and we release the data and
then it becomes persistent
and in retrospect this is not a
surprising thing at all
you know how often you have to update
your web browser because something has
happened with the security you know and
not just the the security of you know
the actual coding but also the
algorithms that are used you know these
um different protocols change over time
because people find attacks are
successful and then they build new
protocols that are that are more secure
to be used um at a later time and we
realize just over time that that that
people learn how to crack various
cryptographic approaches and we're very
accustomed to that that security is not
good in perpetuity and it's not really a
big problem for your web browser because
i don't really care if someone's were
able to be able to crack the
web transactions i did five years ago
because one they probably haven't saved
all those transactions from five years
ago and two even they did i probably
changed my credit card in the interim if
i and even they did they get my credit
card i could then change it now
um but biology is different
and there's actually this article that
was um published last year about dna
kits and this guy michael that's not his
real name he says every time there's a
sale at one of these testing companies
he braces himself for the fact he can
learn about having new kids
he was promised when he provided his
sperm as a sperm donor that he would
have complete anonymity
and instead he keeps learning that he
has more and more children
and this is a this is you know a very
concrete example but we could be doing
this essentially breaking priority
reaching the privacy on an ongoing basis
of essentially everyone who participates
in any type of study where we produce
large-scale functional genomics data
and i think that that's really a grave
um
breach of the promises that are being
made to those individuals
and so the problem is that genome
privacy we have to protect it for a
lifetime and potentially from beyond if
we care about the protection the privacy
of the descendants and these studies as
well
and so i'll conclude there and be happy
to take any questions you might have
again i'll highlight that z chang who
was the postdoc who really led all this
work thank you very much for your
attention
thank you for the fantastic talk stephen
we have time for a lot of questions so
a very intriguing talk thank you so
this is all based on the idea that you
have a genome repositories of
repositories in which you have
centralized genome data right and and
you have that because you need it for
computation purposes to analyze the data
so i was
thinking
what advantages we can expect in
jointly analyzing genome data of genomic
data but actually in a distributed
fashion so that you don't have so i
didn't hear the last in a distributed
fashion so that i mean ideally you will
have the other individual have their own
genomic profile
somehow you can analyze this information
but but without having to put them in a
central repository and i don't know if
there are any
so
what what you need to do this type of
analysis is a central repository of the
genotypes and and some some identifying
information and that exists in the form
of this get match database and as long
as there are people who want to identify
their relatives the databases like that
will just people are voluntarily
contributing to
and you know i haven't put my data into
one of those databases but because my
relatives probably have that i can still
be found via those so those exist
centrally and they're not gonna there's
no reason those would be distributed and
then to identify someone you just need
that one person you don't actually don't
need the data of all the people seeing
the one person and they're in their um
functional genomics data their summary
functional genomics data is able to do
that reinforcement for that individual
so even though they are distributed as
long as you have all of the acute as
long as you have all the qtls or all the
expression levels for that individual
you can then potentially do that
re-identification again it's statistical
that it's not everyone will do this for
but it'll be a significant subset you'll
be able to do it for
do you want to follow up on that
so i just wanted to ask
whether you saw this case um this um
salt murder case that was broadcasted
today and and yesterday where it seems
to be some kind of of um ab initio
approach where you don't need other
genotypes or other genetic sequences
because
from from from this guy
who eventually was convicted
i mean they couldn't find any match in
the databases but there was a
pattern that related to migration from
an italian village
and then the investigator went to
ellis island
records
and found all those who because this
they dated back to 1700s but i think it
was an interesting
situation where you only need the the
genotype or the genome
for the person
and and there's no match in the database
but then you say okay there is a
localization pattern that relates to
italy you go back and and so who
migrated
from that area in the 1700s that turned
out to be 2600 living people today
half of them were female they excluded
those and then they went through them
and they i eventually identified i think
i think it's the it's interesting that
one can also do this without
having a match in the database right
yeah so i think that i think it's
absolutely fascinating that was a really
cool story i don't i actually had not
known as much details you just shared um
it did require still a big public
database but in this case it was the
ellis island immigration database that
they used um and i think it highlights
as i showed earlier on that you really
don't need very many bits of information
to get to unique identifying information
and i just just read it this morning so
it's not something that i started but uh
it was very
much related to
and so there but there are increasingly
more and more big databases that relate
to people so information like that that
is even more indirect can still you can
be increasingly be used so that's
absolutely right thank you
this is not the scientific question it's
actually a reflection i think that if
i'm not drunk
your assumption is that genetic privacy
is is a value that we have to protect
and i could argue that actually genomic
privacy may not be a value that we have
to protect actually in all the cases
that you show
gene lack of genomic privacy help to
uncover immoral behavior
right
so
why
do you think
i mean as far as there are
laws
that protect the get discrimination why
do we need
uh to protect genomic privacy and why it
would not be beneficial for everybody
actually that genomic data is open
for whatever propositive i don't have to
have to hide any moral behavior
why do i need to protect my
so this is a really good question and
there's the second half of the talk that
i didn't present is all about how do we
address this and where are the concerns
um and so you mentioned legislation that
there'd be laws against discrimination
that could be used to help mitigate the
risks of people's genetic privacy being
made public um and i think that those
laws can be very very important
but they're not perfect you know we have
all kinds of laws against discrimination
in this country we still have extensive
discrimination so laws are important to
mitigate harms they're important as
statements of principle but they're not
perfect in the case of genetic privacy
there's a risk that you could basically
someone could offshore the the nefarious
activity and then bring back the
identified data so legislation is not
sufficient there are technological
solutions there are um privacy there are
basically ways to retain and have
confidentially
controlled access to the data i can talk
more about both of those but then the
other thing you can do is simply say you
know what we don't need to keep these
data private there's not a benefit of
keeping these data private and in fact
as i was discussing during the coffee
break that you know i did a calculation
a few years ago and it turns out that a
genome that is without any physical
information but is unrestrictedly
available something like a hundred times
the publication impact of a genome that
is
um that is
in get in dbgap even though that
database that one in dbgap has has all
kinds of rich phenotype associated with
it so making data unrestrictedly
available vastly improves the research
impact of that of those data and so
there's great advantage to not having
genomic privacy and making things
publicly totally publicly open
and for a large number of individuals
who participate in genetic studies
they'll be very happy to have the
information unrestrictedly available
they want the the data to be shared they
want the research to happen um and so i
think that the question you're asking
isn't exactly is exactly the correct one
like if we make the promise to research
participants that we will keep their
data private
then we should do it and i think the
question is should we be making that
promise to them or should we simply give
telling them that this is a study where
your data will not be private
the problem is that if you make if you
insist the data not be private the data
be totally public then then we will
those who have been disadvantaged
historically and are at risk of of
greater harm and marginalization today
will
you know quite rightly choose not to
participate and that will then
recapitulate the biases we've had
historically and so we'll have both less
data but also yet more biased data um
and those who have been marginalized
historically will be even yet more
marginalized going forward and the
biases in our data could be um further
exacerbated so having requiring things
to be totally open and restricted is not
a perfect solution either
but i think it's something that we
should be thinking about a lot more than
we do currently
you have time for one more question
okay
so um
if there are no other questions so
let's thank the speaker again
[Applause]
welcome
for